so is The Stereotype of Islamic
extremism a fair stereotype being fair
we could say this was Christian
terrorism
we're not going to do that it wouldn't
be fair but you can make a case there
because when are you going to apologize
to launch a wholly unjustified and
brutal invasion of Iraq I mean
assalamualaikum greetings of Peace how
are you guys doing we're going to be
discussing are you talking about that
Muslims terrorists violent a video that
came out recently by Patrick Ben David
look if you're easily triggered or
offended this is not the video for you
you are going to get offended we're
going to talk about stereotypes we've
been told that they're out to kill us
all assalamualaikum brothers and sisters
we went to the streets to ask Americans
about Islam here's what they said do you
know anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no sorry you know what Islam means Islam
uh no we've been told they're out to
kill us all that's what you've been told
that Muslims are out to kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you're gonna have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign
trying to bring Muslims together with
Christians to combat the sexualization
of the children but in every issue
abortion Muslims have the lowest
percentage of divorces lowest percentage
of divorces how they feel about abortion
how they feel about lgbtq all of that
stuff Muslims have a conservative belief
and other things they're really seeing
the benefit of working together with
Muslims the parents that were rising up
against the grooming sexual perversion
of children were Muslim families now
there's a particular video and the topic
is about The Stereotype is The
Stereotype of Islamic extremism of fair
stereotype so I'm going to bring out my
next guest and we're going to tackle
this it's under the title our Muslims
the angriest people in the world with
Patrick bit David brought to you by
Patrick and David and we're going to go
ahead and he presented this very nice
but we're going to put some things in
context we're going to go ahead and
dissect this look at it look at the
study that he's quoting and give it
another effective with my next guest
here on the dean show
[Applause]
let me into my face
and his final message
show
[Music]
Dr Bill
um
peace be with you peace be with you and
to the Believers and the people out
there let's start with that this
greeting that I just gave this is really
profound and deep because when you look
at this stereotype
is The Stereotype of Islamic extremism
and then what Patrick been David he goes
into the different stereotypes talking
about the Jewish stereotypes black
stereotypes Asian stereotypes let's get
into this video and then we'll see what
actually how he kicks it off and then
I'll ask you something from there how's
that alhamdulillah let's go stereotypes
are stereotypes accidentally given to
different sects or communities or
religions or ethnicities or is there
some truth behind these stereotypes we
have data top five countries and
terrorism the last 50 years which
countries marriage works out which
religion which countries are the most
angriest we got so much different things
to look at but today's topic a
complicated one we're going to talk
about it some of these stereotypes about
Muslim is true or not okay so he gets
into The Stereotype now particularly
regarding Muslims and Islamic terrorism
he calls it Islamic terrorism when I
opened up the show I said peace be with
you
and just that that comes to my mind is
that how could a group of people
who are greeting wishing peace starting
with peace
we are somehow deemed you know the most
extreme of the stereotypes
shouldn't be right yeah any people and
their book and the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and the faith itself
the foundation of the faith starts with
peace you know Islam comes with the root
word Salama right yes same word uh same
root word for peace
when we greet with each other uh all of
these you know we say that yes Islam is
a faith of Peace Muslims are to uh to
practice that faith and the guidance
Islam has given so when I saw that study
in that video the very first thing that
came to my mind brother Eddie is the
fact that extremism is an act it can be
done by a person of any faith or no
faith Muslims don't have a monopoly on
it
why do I say that because if that is a
French study in a French historically
they are bias because they have been
occupying So Many Lands they have been
destroying so many cultures like in
North Africa and different parts of the
world so extremism uh you cannot just
Define it based upon what only one
culture and one Faith does
you have to Define extremism in that
anyone any faith no faith when they are
destroying property when they are
oppressing the innocent when they're
going into extreme in anything so we
have to make sure
that extremism has to be defined so when
we Define extremism and then we include
the extremist in this country or
anywhere in the world that means that
study is uh going to be flawed if we
include the definition in a most
comprehensive way for example I mean I
would say that every single gun violence
and shooting in this country is an act
of extremism
there have been 500 000 people dying in
this country in the last 25 years by gun
violence so that is extremism so I don't
think that study took that into account
I would say that the 10 million domestic
violence abuses in this country is an
act of extremism yeah I would say that
study has to take that into account I
would say that the millions of women who
have been who have been objectified and
the porn industry and the
objectification of women that is
Terrorism on the opposite gender that
study has to take them into account I
would say that many of the European
countries they have been occupying the
Muslim lands and also the non-muslim
lands every single one of them is an act
of terrorism the British Empire the dash
the French the Spanish the Portuguese
you know for centuries
they have destroyed cultures they have
oppressed people they took away the
wealth of the people they destroyed the
countries after country continent after
continent every single act is an act of
terrorism and an extremism
so I would include and I would suggest
to that French think tank that you guys
have to broaden the definition include
any and all of these things and then we
can see who is number one
here's what I I think we object to if
and I'm sure you agree and Muslims would
agree
it is not fair to call it Islamic
terrorism
the same way it is not fair
everything you just mentioned right now
people would Christians would flaunt
that this is a judeo-christian nation
you hear this always right this is a
judeo-christian nation so it would not
be fair
you could say rightfully so now if this
is a judeo-christian nation that all
these are acts because the people live
there they know Jude jail Christian
Nation majority are Christian parent
practicing or not we don't know
but it wouldn't be fair
but we could do the same thing if you
want to play that and say okay all this
is Christian terrorism
that I mean Islamic terrorism now you're
saying right off the bat that's wrong
that needs to be classified how would
you classify that properly well I mean
if someone says Islamic terrorism
Islamic violence or Islamic extremism I
would divide those two words and say
this is Islam and this is an act
the Theology of Islam obviously it's
peaceful it's proactive it is a blessing
to the world any which way that you look
at it and Muslims are fallible humans a
Muslim can be right and can be wrong so
we cannot judge a faith the best faith
you know the most comprehensive the best
guidance of Islam but the act of a few
misguided people and the Christians
would say the same you know what don't
judge Christianity by the Crusaders by
the KKK by the Andrew breiviks by the
homicides in this country the rapes in
this country right by the abortion
clinic bombers by the Timothy mcveighs
we can go on and on yes I have paper
after paper here right yeah long list of
acts done by the Christians uh but we we
should not label them as Christian
terrorism
terrorism right we should say that these
are Bible Believers and because they are
misguided they are doing these things so
we wouldn't do that you shouldn't do
that let's play Let's play fair but I
wanna I wanna
commend Patrick because I think he's
really going in the right direction
recently I did a response to him and he
had a Christian I don't know if he's a
pastor preacher
Charlie Kurt on his program he also he
mentioned something
regarding Prophet Muhammad being violent
and Jesus being peaceful one of the
reasons they tend to be a violent people
too is because their Prophet was a very
violent person Christ was not right
God's basic training is an optional
program for recruits at Fort Jackson
it's run by the campus Crusade for
Christ
it describes its strategic goals as
evangelize and disciple enlisted U.S
military members throughout their
military careers and build Christian
military leaders to influence the nation
for Christ soldiers brought the New
Testament to Iraq as well this time on
the barrel of a tank as seen in this
official photograph released by the U.S
Marine Corps there are over 25 000
Department of Defense leaders working in
the Rings and corridors of the Pentagon
this video titled Christian Embassy was
widely criticized because it was filmed
in The Pentagon and included interviews
with uniformed officers including four
generals the video was produced by the
campus Crusade for Christ through Bible
studies discipleship prayer breakfast
and Outreach events Christian Embassy is
mustering these men and women into an
intentional relationship with Jesus
Christ
GQ Magazine recently broke a story about
the intelligence reports that then
defense secretary Donald Rumsfeld
personally delivered to President Bush
each day's report began with a
militaristic quote from the Bible oh he
said that yeah so that was the first
program they did and then this is an
independent solo one and we've been in
touch I've
reached out to Patrick we're waiting to
hear back from him Patrick waiting for
you we extended the hand and this is why
it's so important for him to have
Muslims such as yourself
we bring him on I invited him to the
show would you be willing to go to the
Patrick uh podcast yes which is our
brother Patrick you know we uh extend
our hands of friendship and uh you know
nice friendly discussion and these are
important topics we should not shy away
from it because these topics are so
important that people want to hear in a
nice friendly way between Muslims and
Christians and our Jewish friends that
not only the theological points but the
points of contention the way that you
have brought about extremism and
violence and yes anger that Charlie has
brought in then we can come to that too
yeah so this is important that he calls
us to the table so he's talking about us
but not talking with us he should you
gotta talk with us Patrick let's do it
but I'm I'm really I like the direction
he was very respectful how he opened up
here with the stereotypes but I think
now if he gets comes to the table he
sees this hopefully this can open open
up his mind he seemed like he said he
was uh he wanted us to be open-minded
to the information he was presenting so
we want you because and all the
Christians and others out there who are
uncomfortable because they think now
they'll see stuff like this and these
guys are pretty violent right they'll
think you know they'll see the data say
man these guys are ticking time bombs
something can go off anytime no I'm also
really appreciative of uh you know
Patrick for opening this topic and
presenting in a much more balanced way
yeah compared to what other people are
doing but let's not just stop it there
let's extend it more and let's give more
Justice to the data in a more in the
proper context of it
so I think that's when we can do the
proper Justice and that's when our
viewers they can actually you know
analyze and see the faith of Islam and
the background of Muslims and that was
really nice he met this Muslim and they
started getting into a conversation back
and forth and he gives and his
experience that someone that he was
going to work for and get hired by they
thought that okay
they were feeling uncomfortable because
he's Armenian and now the remaining
Community or some Armenians were doing
this insurance fraud thieves they're
thieves so the person brought it up in
his interview and he was fuman he was
upset but he said look give me a shot
let me prove to you you got the job you
came and then he goes on to talk about
how he became one of the top guys and
etc etc but he said he took this and he
didn't take it personal and he made
something of it so he wants us to make
something of it and with all the other
stereotypes but before we go into deeper
he met a Muslim who ended up giving him
a Quran to give and that's what I like
about Patrick he actually brought on one
of the first Muslims on his program you
know who that was Andrew Andrew Tate
yeah yes I saw that one yeah so that was
pretty nice that was pretty cool and
then he gifted him a Quran along with
the Bible and some other book what was
your impression about that well honestly
I didn't watch the whole show but I
really appreciate it again of Patrick
that he wants to hear from the Muslim
side and again so let's not stop at only
and rotate listening to him only invite
us invite other Muslims and Muslim
Scholars so we can have a nice dialogue
and we can chalk out the differences
theological differences especially yeah
and then there are many commonalities
you know the viewers would be surprised
to find out the many many communalities
especially of the values that we uphold
about the LGBT things which is going on
about the morality about the respect of
women in respect of parents you know all
of these moral values and all these
values of decency we have in common so
let's also highlight those that's when
we can see you know what
we can live together we can work
together and we can make Humanity better
by God's guidance
beautiful why there is truth here but
our job on whatever sect you are is to
is to try to change it so I share this
with you to tell you I've been through
it I don't like it and I simply want to
positively change it so try to receive
today's message in a way where you're
open-minded if you're open-minded you
open-minded
open-minded not to the extent of my
things are spelling out okay
we're open-minded Patrick yes so is The
Stereotype of Islamic extremism a fair
stereotype according to a study done by
French Think Tank islamist terrorist
attacks account for 39.1 percent of the
lives lost due to terrorism Between 1979
and 2019. and a matter of fact here's
where the top five countries are leading
the way in terrorist attacks the last 50
years Iraq has experienced the most
terrorist attacks the last 50 years
number two is Afghanistan number three
is Pakistan number four is India the
last but not least in the fifth spot
Syria what do you think well he said a
lot in there okay where should we start
okay let's start with the last one so he
mentioned uh this is not just you know
crime or terrorism to the outside in
occupiers this is like a crime within
your own people like black on black
crime you know people killing of their
own color own culture and own faith what
I would say is you know in the 1979 War
between Iraq and Iran yes sunnisia and
whatnot but they're supported there's a
proxy war they're supported by two
superpowers so in almost all the cases
in the Middle East foreign powers they
are supporting two different fractions
of Muslims
but why just stop up there by the ready
when we look at the history of the U.S
itself when the Civil War was happening
thousands and thousands of people I'm
not sure fifty thousand hundred thousand
people when they died who were they
fighting against
but they're fighting the French Indians
afghanistanis pakistanis who were the
fighting Americans white Caucasian
Christian Americans are fighting each
other so are we going to conclude that
America is a you know angry country
terrorist country you know Christianity
is wrong you know Bible is wrong white
race is wrong no we have to look at the
circumstances we have to look at the
whole picture we have to look the whole
context that's when we can see what is
going on because if you just say in what
Muslims are fighting with each other
then what what's a conclusion if you
conclude something then I can conclude
exactly the same thing to the Christians
and the Jews and the Hindus Hindus
there's so many uh caste system in there
right they hate each other these caste
systems are we going to say every Hindu
is wrong or the Hinduism is wrong or The
Vedas are wrong or the India is wrong so
we just cannot this is really simplistic
way of what you know Patrick is saying
so we need to do more you know analysis
about what exactly country by country
that's big that's when we can figure out
we got to go deeper here then of course
I think a good place now if someone
wants some good data I think Robert Pape
from the University of Chicago funded by
the pentacon has a complete database on
terrorism
and he said he said when drone attacks
go up suicide bombing goes up when
American troops go in as any country and
primarily in the Muslim countries
under democracy and spreading liberalism
and spreading the rainbow pride and all
this alphabet movement
then you have according to Robert Pape
terrorists expert from the University of
Chicago he says bombing goes up so
there's a connection between terrorism
and War are connected this is the
phenomenon here so when he talks about
not before
these drone attacks before these suicide
bombings weren't happening until the
drones until the invasions until the
occupying forces coming in Robert Pape
terrorism expert University of Chicago
funded by the Pentagon Pentagon he says
Iraq Pakistan Afghanistan they weren't
having this type of violence and the
suicide
before this
before 2003 not a single suicide bombing
in the history of Iraq
repeat that before 2003
not a single suicide bombing in the
history of Iraq
what do you think happened in 2003
in the context of what did U.S do to
Iraq
you have the uh the LIE that yes and
that led to
the occupation yes yes so occupation is
directly connected with acts of suicide
bombing and terrorism
splitting off of the fractions you know
the the culture the people the country
the resources
so you know not only Robert Pepe by the
way many many such uh you know Scholars
they have said that the reason people
are angry up there the reason there is
violence up there the reason there is
extremism and uh all kinds of you know
violence number one reason is that
occupation
and this was a many called it because
you had and again just being fair we
could say this was Christian terrorism
we're not going to do that it wouldn't
be fair but you can make a case there
because George Bush was a Christian she
goes on to say quote Gog and Magog are
at work in the Middle East biblical
prophecies are being fulfilled this
confrontation is willed by God who wants
to use this conflict to erase his
people's enemies before a new age begins
end quote and was on some kind of
crusade
to launch a wholly unjustified and
brutal invasion of Iraq I mean of this
Crusade
this this this this this this this
Crusade this Crusade
you had on the did you see some of those
shells some Bible verses and including
this one used to train soldiers in Iraq
contain a secret coded reference to New
Testament passages about Jesus Christ
other sides have references to the New
Testament books of Matthew Revelation
and Corinthians the face of Jesus Christ
the rifle sites are produced by the
Trijicon company of Wixom Michigan which
has almost a billion dollars in Pentagon
contracts the presence of the New
Testament references seem well known as
this gun reviewer pointed out the
passage for the Book of John
[Laughter]
I love it I love it uh yes Trijicon
those guys are Christians and um you
know they they're just in all the
different sites they have verses on
there so just a little neat side note
for those of you who aren't Christians
well you know whatever get over uh the
rifle was referred to as the spiritually
transformed firearm of Jesus Christ
biblical references on the rifle sites
is only the latest example of a clash in
the U.S military over Christian symbols
and preaching in Iraq and Afghanistan
all the tiny biblical codes on the U.S
military rifle sites used by the Army
and the Marines as Tiny as they are seem
certain to raise the issues again
whatever else you know they would have
Christians coming together of the army
units and praying and whatnot we're not
talking about a few Fringe guys a few
marginal characters these were top
commanders in the U.S military openly
flouting the First Amendment uh openly
expressing contempt for other religious
traditions and openly talking about the
wars in Iraq and Afghanistan as as
Lieutenant General Bruce Fister puts a
spiritual war of the highest magnitude
and they were doing this on the record
influence of Evangelical Christianity
within the ranks of the U.S military how
deep does it go they see themselves as a
mission that is emerging god with
American power
they're looking at the mission of the
United States military as very literally
fighting a crusade it's not a metaphor
for them they believe that they are in a
spiritual battle that is equated to
physical battles one officer told me he
says there's angels and there's demons
and we are fighting demons
so if you had certain people who are of
the Muslim faith and Muslims one who
simply surrenders and submits to the
creator of the heavens the Earth one God
Islam means submission to the one God if
you had soldiers in uniform
who are calling Upon Jesus
dear Lord Jesus just come to you in
prayer they were on a mission but it
appears it was not just a military one
United in prayer a group of Evangelical
Christians inside Bagram one of the
biggest U.S spaces in Afghanistan
on the floor of the room two sets of
Bibles the blue ones in Pashto the green
copies in Diary the two main languages
in this deeply conservative Islamic
Society Bible and making prayers you say
they're Christians so they're committing
Christian terrorism
right we're not doing we're not saying
that but you can make a case for that of
course we can make a case the maker
Hughes recorded U.S army chaplain Gary
Hensley in a provocative sermon at
Bagram Air Base you know special the
Special Forces guys they hunt men
basically
the same thing as Christians we hunt
people for Jesus but we should not we
cannot because it's not just you know we
cannot blame Bible or Christianity or
Jesus peace be upon him for the acts of
violence done in the name of
Christianity or done by the Christians
in a two quick examples I can give
brother Eddie
the data that he showed by the French
Think Tank 39 violence this year to this
year done by the Muslims
if you look at from an objective way
from the factual way right from any data
that you can look at it the number one
uh you know acts of terrorism that I can
say or the most number of civilians
killed in the last century they were
done by who which countries Muslim
countries or non-muslim countries
World War One close to 19 million
civilians wow they died or they were
killed actually fighting between the
Christian countries due to the fighting
between Christian countries 54 Krishna
54 million not 54. 54 million civilians
non-combatants that were killed because
of the war
right after the second world war between
the Christian countries so are we going
to say that Christianity is the most
violent Faith because they have killed
like you know 100 million people
even though that's a fact but we don't
blame Christianity or the Bible or Jesus
peace be upon him we blame those
Christians and that geopolitical
situation so in the same way in case if
you see some Muslims in some countries
because of the occupation now people are
angry and now it's a proxy war in that
proxy where people are getting killed we
cannot blame Islam or the Muslim culture
or Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him we
blame those foreign powers and those
misguided Muslims
if you look at and this is what Robert
Pape University of Chicago funded by the
Pentagon terrorist expert look them up
he talks about this is geopolitical he
says nothing to do with Islam so you
can't call this Islamic terrorism that's
the thing that I want Patrick says his
open mind I believe you do and people
can be misinformed I think you get in a
different perspective him and Charlie
Kirk I look forward to have connected
also with Charlie cook Kirk and I think
him also people can get information it
could be the wrong information they
don't sit that's why it's important to
sit with the Muslims to talk to go ahead
and open your mind and and get the other
perspective and other facts that you
might not have come across you might not
have looked into this is very important
what about the war
and Europe This is the greatest genocide
after World War II and you can clearly
see they were blessing again with all
respect and if you like Patrick said if
your mind is on open if you're stubborn
if you're not looking to
um as the wise man said the the mind if
it's not open like a parachute you know
what I mean you gotta go ahead and to
get it work right it's got to be open
otherwise it's not going to work so
we're respectfully bringing these things
up not to be like I got you here got you
there but to give that broader
perspective Bosnia you had What's called
the the techniques you had their guns
being blessed by the Orthodox priest
they came in and they did a Slaughter
and we're not going to blame all serbs
it's not good that's not the right thing
to do but you had they we we're not
going to bring blame Christianity but
the uh slobanon milosevic look them up
Patrick uh look at the rather Von
karovic they were in the church they
were with the priests getting the guns
blessed and they did a massacre under
the U.N protection the people came
celebrity and they thought they were in
a safe Zone next thing you know even the
U.N yeah they left them women and
children women raped
it was a massacre it was it was over
eight thousand there's still it just
passed July 11th uh every year new bones
remnants are found and they're doing the
janazas the burials now that's just one
part of Bosnia I mean you had like and
you know what if you look at it if you
look at go and do your research all the
masjids the Moss were destroyed they
were brought down to the ground but the
Muslims looked us up Patrick
Damas the churches were left untouched
look at this standing behind a Catholic
Church a Catholic Church one interesting
thing is that is this true that during
the war this is the greatest genocide
that had happened after World War II
here and pretty much uh we don't blame
Christianity even though it was a
crusade against Muslims but we don't
blame Christianity even though it was
hijacked at that time but that's just an
interesting point but another even more
interesting point is that Muslims
executing the teachings of Islam and
Prophet Muhammad's orders you will not
have seen if they weren't following
Islam Islam preserved this church is
that right that's right like in Sarajevo
I don't know the number of the churches
so how many churches are in Sarajevo but
not a single one during the three and a
half years occupation of sarajeva was
destroyed this is the main Church of
Sarajevo it's in downtown like the
straight downtown area
the only thing that that
it wasn't destroyed but the grenades
from the from the Serbian side that
dropped thousands over 500 000 grenades
during the two and a half years
and uh
that's the only damage it it got the
charges from those grenades so not not a
single church was destroyed or anything
by the Muslim side by the bosnians
so before the Geneva Convention code
there was the mercy that the Creator
sent through the Mercy to Mankind
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him who said don't kill in the
innocent non-combatants now when you're
fighting in combat you know what are you
going to send a guy you know love letter
no you're in combat against an enemy
self-defense but we're talking about now
the places of worship
they're off limits so unlike others who
are just destroying demolishing Moss and
houses of worship Islam forbids that and
that's why this is we're able to stand
in front of a church right here and
witness that and we just heard the Bell
right yeah also it's been all the time
during the war the Bell was here and uh
like I said not a single church was
destroyed or damaged by the bosnians by
the Muslims during the war there's also
50 meters down there there's a Serbian
Orthodox Church the serbs occupy the
town it was occupied for two and a half
years
and the church in downtown Sarajevo
wasn't touched by the Muslims by the
bosnians because the church didn't
occupy the the the city the the military
the Army the Serbian Army did by the
Muslims by the Muslims that's important
that's important for the viewers to know
it's Haram it is forbidden extremely
forbidden in Islam to destroy places of
worship
look at that did you know that yes and
Muslims it doesn't matter which
geopolitical situation that you are in
even in the extremes of War we still
protect the churches the synagogues and
places of worship and that is Real Islam
actually
so one more example I was going to give
is you know when people when they bring
this data about Muslims are you know
violent and angry and all of that I
think some part of the video mentions
that you know it's important for us not
to lump all the 2 billion Muslims into
one bucket we are not monolithic so I
would divide them into three different
buckets or three different categories
the first one would be Muslims as
minorities like you and me living in
non-muslim countries may that be Europe
as continent Australia right over here
in the USA Canada the second set of
Muslims I would say are Muslims living
in majority Muslim countries in which no
war is going on
OK got it the third category in the last
category is Muslims in which
Muslim majority countries in which war
is going on
so let's take a look at the very first
one Muslim says minority like USA are
living in a non-muslim predominal this
country
Muslims are a model community in this
country why because according to the
survey we are the most charitable people
right you heard that right yes last year
two years ago we are a model Community
Muslims right we have the same Quran
Muslims we are one of the most highly
educated people we are the most diverse
people we are the most uh people having
the most positive and peaceful impact on
the society
so when we look at from those sub
metrics we are a model Community the
Muslims
when we take a look at the Muslims
majority Muslim countries in which no
war is going on Indonesia turkey
Malaysia right those countries they're
also model Muslim countries
the Jews the Christians even the Hindus
the atheists they are living in with the
peace and harmony with no oppression but
living under Justice
it is only the third category of the
Muslims living in a Muslim predominant
country in which war is imposed foreign
occupiers are there even when the
foreign occupants when they left they
impose the dictators on it so because of
that oppression
Muslims are angry I would be angry you
should be angry right I mean when Japan
attacked Pearl Harbor 1945 or so U.S
become angry and then what did they do
they went and they did what Hiroshima
Nagasaki 300 000 innocent people died so
anger can be justified at some times and
not every anger is negative important
I'm I'm angry at all the oppression
going on you should be angry right
Patrick should be angry I'm angry at
shaitan for example I'm angry at all the
pedophiles I'm angry at all the drug
dealers so anger is not always a
negative emotion right
yeah so so when the video says you know
what Muslims are the angriest of all the
people I mean in the later segment uh
then we have to look at the cause of the
anger because by itself if you bring the
aspect that Muslims are angry that's
incomplete incomplete data you have to
look at why are Muslims angry or some
Muslims I should say right
uh because of Oppression maybe the Drone
missiles maybe the proxy wars maybe the
dictators and the oppression going on
right those segments of Muslims you know
I was before this show I was looking at
some data
Americans our fellow Americans are angry
at so many things over here okay they're
angry at the health care System the
economic system uh the political system
correct educational system in which
parents are taken away their rights from
how to educate their children so U.S
every single member of the U.S every
single cities and we are angry at
certain uh you know part of the U.S
government just because you are angry we
cannot conclude anything from it it's
incomplete we have to look at the reason
for the anger so that's the whole point
brother Patrick
if you look at other statistics if you
look at and before I get into those real
quick I mean
you can think why would people be angry
and the countries that he listed were
pretty much bombed back into the Stone
Age like Iraq Afghanistan they were
invaded imagine people coming from China
over here
and they want to spread communism they
want to spread their belief system to us
you wouldn't be happy with that would
you you'd be upset you'd be angry
rightfully so human nature that's human
nature so you're coming over here based
on a lie it was a lie weapons of mass
destruction now it's uncovered and
reason we went under Iraq time was we
thought he had weapons of mass
destruction it turns out he didn't
those weapons of mass destruction got to
be somewhere
when are you going to apologize
foreign
and you go over there you kill the
people you blow them back into the Stone
Age and you create this unrest what do
you think and then you pass on you know
then you start putting up uh you try to
put up uh these uh Rango flags and you
know the porn the satellite the porn
you're spreading liberal the secularism
and this way of life that the people
don't want yeah yeah and now people uh
there's a great documentary called Dirty
Wars you know you got people in these
caves eating real food you know family
and they're hanging out the next you
know drone from 10 000 miles away 10 000
miles uh 10 000 feet up in the air boom
and now this man this family this wife
and husband uh they brought up their
child about to get married and you just
destroyed their their life and how many
of these have have happened in
Afghanistan and in Iraq and Pakistan
Pakistan and all these other places so
it's it's it's interesting that these
are the places where these statistics
where now it's like for example you come
in and someone comes to your house
Patrick imagine this and to your
neighborhood to your house and the crook
and the criminal comes in beats up your
family and takes all your possessions
turns things upside down and then when
you go to you know defend yourself now
they say oh now now they use you as the
the violent one
come on man right so one of the ways
that I would advise brother Patrick and
uh you know Charlie who was there in the
show and anyone else you know unbiased
viewers we need to compare apples to
apples so the way that I would sit by
the Eddie to compare okay let's compare
a U.S in which no war is going on in the
mainland right good good point know what
is going on okay let's compare that to a
Muslim majority country like turkey in
which no war is going on in the mainland
about Qatar
so let's for the sake of argument U.S
comparing it to Turkey all right so I
have the data over here so when it comes
to uh when it comes to drugs uh us has
seven times more drug dealing compared
to Turkey all right when it comes to uh
murder rate
five times more compared to Turkey
all right when it comes to the rate of
rapes the rate of assaults the rate of
uh you know pornography the rate of uh
oppression every single metric that you
can look at us is many times more than
turkey
how about if you do the same thing
cutter is one of the safest places to
live yes and also Dubai very they are
high on the statistics of and this is a
majority Muslim country Malaysia
say these are the safest places in the
world to live Medina was rated for women
wanted to save these safest places in
the world you know this statistic really
there's Dina yes yeah I think I will
show that Medina and this is the the
heart of Islam here so this data
if anyone goes to
nationmaster.com right it's a good
website and the data in there is
compiled by the U.N by the CIA by the
FBI so this kind of you know quote
unquote credible data so if anyone go to
nationmaster.com and then you can do the
search by the metric of assaults uh
robbery rapes right drug dealing
homicide suicide
and they compare 200 countries almost
all the time for all of these different
metrics the non-muslims country they're
rank the highest
of all the countries the non-muslim
countries are ranked the highest in all
of these in unfortunate data
yeah so what do we conclude do we blame
Christianity for it or do we blame that
culture that geopolitical situation
because it goes back to we started if
it's a judeo-christian nation what's it
producing and at the end of the day if
all it's just through the roof crime is
through the roof you got uh mother
coming home just recently this has
happened all over the place did you know
this is a uh actually a Muslim woman in
hijab she was coming home and then guys
come up take her purse husband comes out
did you see this one this was in Skokie
in Chicago but anyways I mean theft is
just through the roof Islam has the
solutions amputation after the four
people have been fed the zakat has been
implemented and when when Islam when
actually if you look at the Islamic
history when Islam was actually
implemented they were looking for who to
give money to they were everybody was
taken care of yes in the time of uh Umar
bin Abdul Aziz
1717 until 17 19 approximately people
went out to give money to the poor the
zakatmani which is an obligation for
Muslims to give and they knocked at
their stores everyone opened the door
and say we don't want it we are content
we have enough right imagine over here
even before we approach somebody people
are going to take away and run with the
money right it's that's what Islam
produced you you go through some cities
some neighborhoods in Chicago Gary
Indiana Chicago I mean imagine if you
took just a portion of that money that
you're spending over here with the with
the the wars the War Machine and going
into other countries and bombing and
drones and all that if you invested that
here imagine how many how how much of
the problems you can go ahead homeless
people I mean you got people defecating
in the street in California and other
places homeless the homeless situation
is just through the roof so I think the
best thing we can't just sorry are we
going to blame Christianity on that say
this is uh you know Christians are now
this is the Christian terrorism because
of that and not no so it goes back to
where we started it's not fair to call
this Islamic terrorism and Islam is
producing all these army people is Islam
is it Christianity is the jail Christian
Nation now because of it is now it's
this is because of that that this is
being produced the fruits of it we can
say the same thing about South America
predominantly a Catholic continent
predominantly right in which education
is like really low people are dropping
off from high school marriages are you
know been breaking up uh drug abuses
rampant up there uh so unemployment is
rampant homicide is going on right
really you know really high so we cannot
blame Catholicism or the Bible uh for
the State of Affairs in the South
America so in the same way it's not fair
for anyone to look at Middle East or
some Muslim countries some population
and say you know what how come they are
extremists how come they are angry how
come there is Terrorism we have to look
at from a bigger perspective look at the
causes for it looking at the causes does
not mean we are justifying it this is so
important by the Eddie people may be
thinking you know what you guys are just
playing a victim card you're justifying
it no we are not even if Muslims are
oppressed they cannot go and oppress
other people
because the Quran itself says saving one
innocent life is like saving the life of
all of humanity and taking one innocent
life is like taking the life of all of
humanity right chapter 5 verse 32 and
onwards
so uh so so the way that we can conclude
this is going back to Islamic sources
all right so this is culture here is uh
the Muslims uh fallible Muslims right uh
they are product of their culture and
then you have the perfect peaceful a
blessed faith of Islam and actually in
these places you have again with the
porn being brought in this is all under
the secularism liberalism and now
actually that's what it's producing it's
the same culture from here you're
pushing it over there and this is
causing the problems true uh and now now
we have all of this um This Disaster but
if you look at Dr Sabio I want to go
back to this where Charlie Kirk he went
and he mentioned something and hopefully
when we sit and he sits with Muslims
hopefully they can invite us on we can
talk and get to the bottom a lot of
these things and get a different
perspective a lot of even history you
gotta like they don't teach you this
stuff in school
I was um I posted something I tweeted
something there was this uh Professor
American professor and he was teaching
some of the stuff that we're talking
about about when Muslims came in and and
I'll talk about touch upon this morning
they came in and they they conquered
certain areas you know how they went and
the the justice that was ex that was
established and because Christians were
being oppressed they wanted the Muslims
to come in and to liberate now this
point how would you deal with this and
we can get into more what uh on what I'm
talking about where he he said that um
Muhammad and we love Jesus but he said
also peace be upon him he said because
Jesus is peaceful and Muhammad is
violent that's why the Muslims are
violent one of the reasons they tend to
be a violent people too is because their
Prophet was a very violent person Christ
was not right
how would you go ahead and address that
well first and foremost we need to
correct that statement and we say Jesus
peace be upon him he was peaceful he was
the Prince of Peace Muhammad peace be
upon him and all the prophets they were
Prince of Peace
and obviously we need to look into the
life of Muhammad peace be upon Him
compared to the really short Ministry of
Jesus right peace be up so the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him his ministry
his prophethood it spanned from the year
610 all the way to the year 632 so
during that time when he was peacefully
preaching to the makkans uh he did not
waste a finger he was like peaceful uh
he was uh you know oppressed by the
people Muslims are getting killed but
still not a single bullet not a single
gun or sword was raised
however when they came after his life
and then the life of the Believers and
they finally kicked him out
it is a god-given right for every single
uh you know human to defend themselves
so in that self defense many words were
fought by Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him
so Islam is a peaceful faith it is not a
passive fist faith means Islam is a
practical Faith you know I mean I can
ask any person who is watching over here
what would you do 2 am in the morning in
knock at the door you see from the [__]
and you see that you know people are out
there with the chains with knives and
with guns what are we going to do we'll
pick up the baseball bat we have an
alarm system we'll uh you know press the
alarm we'll call 9-1-1 obviously we will
defend our honor of our family our you
know wife our children our property
so Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
had that many wars with the people who
came to destroy Islam and the Muslims
every single one of them
so in that context Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he picked up weapons
ordered by the Creator the same way
Prophet Moses peace be upon him
the same way prophets of the Old
Testament they picked up weapons to
fight the enemy
so in that context we say Muhammad peace
be upon Him is the Prince of Peace but
he was a practical person
he was a person he want to show by
example don't just you know be chicken
and you know be sheep and let violence
and people oppress you be a man stand up
for your rights protect your women your
girls your family and your honor so that
is a prophet
the profit of practicality the blessings
for Humanity and he showed us in every
circumstances how to live in God's
guidance and how to better the society
with God's guidance
Jihad the struggling now because this is
what people usually attack and they say
this is violent and they don't even know
that it doesn't mean holy war The The J
is a just War even before the Geneva
Convention came out you know to preserve
decent values freedom to worship
protection of Monastery churches Mass
Jihad is a quest for justice and peace
and it's not fair that you put Jesus
and uh situation trying to compare to
Muhammad because this what you said he
wasn't given political power
yeah but if you compare him to Moses for
example there you go what happened when
Moses came back and the people are
worshiping the calf and just in one shot
what was that 3 000 people were were
executed
so now do we discredit Moses from being
a prophet if you compare all of the
violence that was there and if you look
at Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him I ask them to look at they
can do this homework how many people
actually died through all of these
different battles that happen how many
people actually died in those battles
altogether how many people actually died
by Muhammad peace be upon him his sword
right you would think you know they
praise people like Alexander degrade and
they you know all these different
figures and but if you look at Prophet
Muhammad
and he came in after being tortured
after the robbing the Looting that they
took from them
and all the oppression the conquest of
Mecca when he came back ten thousand
strong can you imagine that look imagine
this Patrick Charlie all the Christians
and all the people out there just read
about this this
magnanimous thing that he did
forgiving those who did the worst
atrocities to your followers to your
family and he actually came in not as
pumping his chest but humble with his
head down saying spread the peace Spread
salams spread the food spread the peace
who does that so the what brother is
saying is that you know the people who
tortured the prophet peace be upon Him
kicked him out from his homeland you
know Makkah kill several of the
Believers took away the property so when
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him when
he came back to Mecca from Madina with
ten thousand of his soldiers
and now the prophet and his people has
the upper hand
and then he asked his people right the
people who used to torture him the
prophet asked them what do you think I
am going to do to you and they said you
are our brother we expect the best from
you and then he said today all of you
are forgiven that is the Prince of Peace
that is the person who we can learn from
aspect of mercy and forgiveness and love
and empathy that's amazing but you can
you can play that game and you can go
ahead and again
um that's not the agenda here we're not
trying to do that but many people end up
playing this game but you can come back
and say and quote certain verses where
Jesus said look of my enemies who wish
to not not Reign Over them bring them
here and slay them in front of me right
I came to divide father from you can you
can go ahead and bring certain things
but you can also talk about when he
comes back there you go what's going to
happen he said he's going to establish
Sharia God's law yes what did he say and
then he's going to come back and kill
all the infidels means the
non-christians okay yeah I mean I'm just
using that language that's what
Revelation the last book of the Bible
says when Jesus comes back every
non-believer means non-christians they
would be done with
so is that the Prince of Peace we say
yes he is still the Prince of Peace even
when he comes in the second coming
you know we would say he is going to
follow the Sharia Allah's guidance he
will follow Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him He will humbly pray with
forehead on the ground worshiping the
Creator
and Rule with Justice and peace all over
the world that was another thing that
Charlie in the episode that I addressed
he mentioned that the reason that many
Christians they believe because Muslims
they want to come in and establish
Sharia I share some of this right belief
that radical Muslims want to bring
Sharia to the United States
and we often you often say that Sharia
is already here is here how is that
me smiling at all of you and you we are
following the Sharia
very soon we are going to pray the third
prayer of the day which is part of the
Sharia in U.S we are of practicing
Sharia if I go to Chicago downtown and
give five dollars or food to a poor
person I am following Sharia if I go
home and take care of my parents I am
following Sharia if I'm going up in the
morning and uh you know working to get a
food on the table I am following Sharia
if I'm being nice to women not
objectifying them I'm following Sharia
if I'm having rallies Against Racism in
this country
I am following Sharia or if you're
uniting now for a common good like
Patrick wants to do and Charlie wants to
do on a common platform common good to
unite against the sexualization of the
children you're following God's laws
Sharia Sharia yes and as we have said
many times in the past Sharia is there
in the Old Testament New Testament Jihad
started from the Old Testament right
Moses and David and Solomon all these
Prophet they fought Jihad Jihad means
they are struggling to establish God's
guidance to rule with Justice morality
and unity in those lands that is Jihad
so Jihad is there in the Old Testament
Sharia is there all over the Bible
Patrick mentions a few more things
before we conclude he mentioned in this
video here why what
which prophet they believe in so he
talked about Jesus or Muhammad maybe
these guys have a lot more in common
except who they believe is their Prophet
Jesus or Muhammad but this is something
that we believe in both yes it's not
either or it's not either so they're not
mutually exclusive it is both
maybe for some other time we can mention
later on the prophecies about Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him in the Old
Testament and in the New Testament so if
you actually believe in the Bible you
have to take Muhammad peace be upon him
also as a prophet also as a last prophet
so if you read the Quran and I advise
every single viewer especially Patrick
and Charlie and all of you to read the
Quran uh the Quran does mention with
high honor uh Jesus and Moses and all
the prophets if you read the Bible and
the prophecies in there they are
prophecies about Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him in the Old Testament in the
New Testament for that reason Jews and
the Christians of the past they started
to live in Medina awaiting that prophet
and when he came some of them they
embraced the faith of Islam so it's not
either or both of them they are sent by
the Creator they both were the prophets
they both perform Miracles by Allah's
power they both invited people to
worship the one Creator and just like
they invited people to worship the one
Creator and not the creation we invite
our viewers to read the Quran and
worship the Creator and not the creation
that's the way brother Eddie right to
establish justice and peace and unity
and morality in the world and then what
is the reward in the hereafter
Paradise Eternal Paradise yeah why you
just got me thinking about when you talk
about Prophet Muhammad peace and blessed
be upon him uh just uh
is amazing you mentioned the Quran we're
not killing one innocent being as
non-combatants like you know killing all
the humanity The Rules of Engagement are
really clear in Islam you cannot go and
kill innocent men women and children
non-combatants so so we covered this
whole Islamic terrorism thing let's so I
want to make that clear hopefully he can
pull back from that after we gave some
examples of where we can make a case for
Christian terrorism and you can see
where now these is a false stereotype
and this is something that with the
proof and evidences and the proper data
and everything this gets pretty much
debunked uh now moving on a love for
Jesus the commonalities now and he did
that video of what Christians and
Muslims have become we have so much in
common yeah and when you mention Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
uh it reminded me uh even in the Bible
and this is a whole different topic but
um Isaiah 29 12 when the book is given
to the one who has not learned talking
about Prophet Muhammad so you have
Prophecies of prophet Muhammad actually
in the Bible yes yeah so we have uh so
much that we can talk about these are
things that we can go ahead and make a
strong case for the pure monotheism and
the message of Jesus why we believe he's
a prophet because he was called a
prophet in the Bible he was called The
Prophet Prophet from Nazareth correct
human Jesus Jesus yeah many times yeah
Matthew 13 57 yeah Luke 13 33 you know
Mark 6 4 John 4 44. many places when he
performed Miracles people did not say
you know that is God that Son of God
they said that's a prophet yeah there's
two there's so many things so many
topics these go we can go deeper into
these and it'll be very interesting to
come on and discuss these things and
um
this thing about Muslims you know when
Christians hear that and I had
Christians come on and when they went
from being complete islamophobes hating
Muslims in Islam and they were like why
do we hate these Muslims when they say
Jesus they say peace be upon them but
then there's another group of people
that they believe his mother was uh
a what do you call someone who has sex
out of wedlock they disrespect her they
disrespect Jesus peace be upon they call
him all slanderous names and evil names
we're over here you can go to the
Hellfire if you disrespect Jesus Islam
is this correct exactly so you heard me
say it I'm not making this stuff up
not only you disrespect even if you
don't believe that Jesus was a prophet
you are nullifying one of the Articles
of Faith you have to believe in him and
all the prophets so if you before so if
you compare all the things that we have
in common now and this is where we'll
finish it off where the uniting now
against the sexulation of the children
you know the pushing of this agenda
chopping off good healthy body parts and
whatnot that obviously we're on the same
page here uniting on would you be
interested now do you think now you have
a big reach I have a big reach would you
be interested in collaborating with
people like Charlie uh Kurt and uh
Patrick and David they're actually doing
some good work they're traveling I think
to California to go ahead and to see
other parents who are also on the same
page
if the Muslim Community knew more about
this and you think through your message
and other Muslims that this is something
that they would want to be a part of
I know that's a really good point uh
that we want our youth our children to
be protected from what is going on in
the public school especially and in the
popular culture
so I think on that point on that value
on that commonality that we have I would
really urge Charlie and Patrick you know
and uh mothers out there like-minded
let's come together let's have a chat
and let's work out a strategy how we can
at least uh unite on that front so
inshallah God willing as we say we are
at least protecting the children and
then we can at least say later on that
we did something and that's one of the
important sunnis means one of the
examples of prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him that you know even before he
was 40 years of age
him along with the Christians and the
Jews and the idol worshipers they came
together for the common uh cause of
removing the oppression from the society
so God loves that the prophet he loved
it and if we do it inshallah we are also
following the Sunnah that means we are
coming on a common platform to remove
the oppression protect the children and
please the Creator
can you narrate the story of there was
in Medina in Mecca you had the pack that
was made yes can you talk about this
pact it's also Muslims also see because
some Muslims they don't actually know
about this but the prophet saws came
together to fight against Injustice and
other things yes so so what happened was
uh so Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
he was in Madina so in the city of
Madina they were Merchants you know
businesses they were selling each
other's goods and people used to come
from different places and buy and sell
so one time it so happened that one of
the merchants that came one of the
sellers he came from outside of Madina
and he was selling so actually this was
in Mecca Mecca yeah he was in Mecca
right so he was selling something and
then he sold the goods but the buyer
refused to give him the money and one of
the prominent horish person was the
buyer and then this Merchant he was
raising his voice you know uh Injustice
is being done to me somebody helped me
and nobody was helping so when Muhammad
peace be upon him when he heard about it
he said you know what something has to
be done so he called the people of
different faiths even the idol
worshipers and they said let's have a
pact call The Pact of the righteous the
allegiance of The Virtuous which is
called as the hillful fudul so they all
came together uh knowing that they have
theological differences but there is
something in commonality they want to
remove the oppression from the society
they came together and because of that
they were able to reduce and remove the
oppression Society became better Common
People good-hearted people despite their
differences coming on a common platform
we can do the same inshallah today so to
call Prophet Muhammad violent he's
supposed to be upon him if he's fighting
against someone who's trying to disrupt
that peace and that Justice just like
the police officer and just like the
person who's defending his family in his
home it's not correct to go and call
someone violent just like if Moses is
going and doing something
this is very important to put things in
context so if someone is still out there
is talking about Prophet Muhammad is
violent look at you have to go deeper
and look at the context why certain
events happen right and we go and this
is something again this is something to
talk about and this is why we're
addressing this that you can go ahead
and freely ask certain questions we can
we can go ahead and discuss certain
topics and we can go ahead and and put
it out there discuss it and see the
different perspective and if your mind's
open you're going to be like hold on I
wasn't thinking about that that makes
sense but you know but so really quickly
then we can wrap up especially to
brother Charlie over here you know God
forbid if you're saying that Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him was a violent
person how come he uh he gives such
honor to our mothers to the wives and
the daughters Paradise is under your
mother's yes if he wear violence God
forbid how come he said you know go and
help your neighbors if he were violent
why did he forgive his enemies if he
were violent why did he stop the
infanticide if he were violent why did
he stop the intoxicants from the society
if he were violent why did he remove uh
racism from the society all of these
metrics is not a person who is violent
it's a person who is a prince of peace
not only for two years but for all
eternity that's Muhammad peace be upon
so we covered a lot anything else that
you wanna you wanna mention well just at
the end of the day right let's separate
the people from the peaceful faith of
Islam and if you want to know what Islam
is you know because I have read the
Bible I want to know who the Christians
are their holidays their theology right
their history I read the Bible and I bet
many of our fellow Christians the Jews
and the people of non-muslim Faith you
may not have read the Quran we can send
you a free copy of the Quran free of
charge right no strings attached you can
give us a call at
1-800-662 Islam
1-800-662 Islam or you can go to the
website gainpeace.com
Spanish copy or English translation of
the Quran all right but last but not the
least to pray to the same creator
the way that Jesus used to pray
for giving us guidance for giving us uh
the the best in this world and for with
God's mercy Paradise in the Hereafter so
may God guide each one of you may God
bless each one of you so we can live in
peace and Harmony as brothers and
sisters so God by his Mercy can put us
into Paradise I mean beautiful I think
we end with that we covered a lot and
hopefully people with open mind sincere
heart they can look at this and they can
go ahead and make a better
distinction between Islam like you said
and the actions of human beings who are
fallible who make mistakes and you don't
want to judge Islam by the riffraff out
there the same way you don't judge
Christianity by the riffraff and the
criminals and whoever else so let's be
fair let's be balanced and let's unite
on goodness and we'll see you next time
subscribe if you haven't already look
forward to hearing from you Mr Patrick
and let's make this
a reality I was coming together on a
common platform to do some common good
to protect the children and all the
other things that are out there that we
can go ahead and work on to make
Humanity a better place for all with
that said peace be with you
I'm Dr Daniela that I'm so excited to be
here at the dean Center mashallah which
is under renovation and I can't wait to
see what's going to come inshallah
there's going to be a dawa Center
there's a Masjid there's a school in
Islamic school a gym and what we hope
inshallah will also have a mental health
part of this Center as well inshallah so
I'm asking you to please make sure that
you support this effort inshallah I
really hope that it spreads and really
the knowledge of Islam and people get to
know more about Muslims at Islam for
this effort
[Music]
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedenshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you